in a stunning breakthrough president
trump said israel and the united arab
emirates have agreed to establish
full diplomatic relations for the first
time mr trump took
credit in the oval office for brokering
the historic deal it's part of the
middle east peace effort led by jared
kushner his son-in-law and senior
advisor
charlie dagetta in london has more
charlie good morning what is behind
this deal good morning well this is a
deal that's going to have
huge ramifications across the region the
big
loser is iran we were there in the uae
when iran started attacking and seizing
oil tankers which
they started to do again this week the
uae has been an
important u.s ally with american forces
based there
but the gulf nation has had to tread
carefully not to provoke iran
that's clearly no longer the case when
you take sides with
iran's sworn enemy now it obviously
benefits
israel and having another important and
wealthy friend in the neighborhood
finally although the palestinians say
they've been betrayed by the uae
the deal puts israel's plan to annex
parts of the west bank on hold
at least for now as both countries
benefit from diplomatic ties
trade and technology the hope is that
fellow arab nations
may follow suit vlad
all right charlie dagetta in london
charlie thank you very